[Musique]
lubin
bienvenue dans hogwarts legacy
l'héritage de poudlard vous venez
d'intégrer la célèbre école de
sorcellerie et vous avez un lien avec
une puissante et ancien magie enfouis
dans le monde des sorciers vous devrez
découvrir ce qui se cache derrière le
retour de cette magie oublié et qui
cherche à l'exploiter pour anéantir le
monde des sorciers car c'est peut-être
vous qui décideraient du sang de ces
derniers
mais avant de pouvoir étudier la magie
et commencer à résoudre ses mystères
vous devez créer votre sorcière ou votre
sorcier
en arrivant à poudlard vous serez envoyé
dans l'une de ces quatre maison
gryffondor poufsouffle serdaigle ou
serpentard après votre installation dans
le dortoir vous rencontrerez vos
camarades dans la salle commune vous
devrez ensuite assister aux cours et
vous aurez du travail car vous commencé
sur le tard en cinquième a eu lieu à
bagdad vous participerez au cours de
sortilèges de défense contre les forces
du mal de botanique et de potions pour
n'en citer que quelques-uns
[Musique]
l'arrivée du haut débit
à claudie haigneré du cash money a
doctor web bataille contre le chômage
y
est allé
[Musique]
dumont beghi
tesco contrer vos professeurs et
apprenez à lancer des sorts cultiver les
plantes magiques préparer des potions et
plus encore entre les cours vous pourrez
explorer le château bien connu pour ses
secrets ses enchantements et ses
mystères
[Musique]
vous découvrirez des cachots des
passages secrets
[Musique]
mais aussi des énigmes qui demanderont
des compétences magiques et de
l'ingéniosité pour être résolus
vous pourrez même vous rendre dans
certains lieux emblématiques auparavant
inaccessibles
nous sommes à la fin des années 1800 si
les lieux et les cours vous semble
familier ce ne sera pas le cas de vos
professeurs toutefois vous reconnaîtrez
peut-être quelques visages
[Musique]
vous apprendrez à connaître des sorciers
des sorcières talentueux en classe mais
aussi en effectuant des devoirs
supplémentaires dans le cadre d'un
programme spécial conçu pour vous aider
à rattraper les autres élèves de 5e
année à votre rythme
[Musique]
les possibilités davanture foisonnent
dans les environs de poudlard les
compétences magiques que vous apprenez à
maîtriser en classe seront bientôt mises
à l'épreuve tandis que vous ai lu cidre
est un dangereux mystère aux côtés du
professeur figues aussi talentueux et
énigmatique pour tenter de découvrir si
les rumeurs d'une révolte des gobelins
sont fondées et si la sécurité de
poudlard
non
[Musique]
le monde des sorciers de cette époque
regorge de danger créatures qu'on tue
par une force magique puissant gobelins
images redoutable tous prêts à combattre
et à tuer pour servir leurs propres
intérêts
à vrai dire une alliance fragile s'est
formé entre les gobelins et des mages
noirs
il s'est du coup d'état jonny kane des
hawks louis melou you need it ou
était-ce touax
preview destruction
mentale mais peut-être devriez-vous
faire profil bas pour l'instant
[Musique]
les ennemis disposent de nombreuses
compétences comme le maléfice explosif
le sortilège de stups et fiction d
armement chanter et plus encore si
certains vous attaquent directement
d'autres peuvent vous ensorceler et vous
neutraliser
maîtriser le charme du bouclier afin de
dévier les sorts à distance et les
attaques de mêlée
[Musique]
contre attaquer grâce à de puissants
sortilèges de stups et fiction qui
permettent d'enchaîner d'autres
combinaisons de sort
les élèves doués en sortilèges sauront
trouver de nombreux moyens d'exploiter
les faiblesses de leurs ennemis
[Musique]
assommés avec 17,2
grillé avec une scène dior
anéantissez vos adversaires avec
différents coup de grâce
vous pouvez recourir à la mystérieuse
magie incomprise de vos professeurs pour
anéantir vos plus puissants ennemis
combinant des dizaines de sort vous
pourrez développer votre style de combat
pour devenir le meilleur duellistes
[Musique]
rires
tu fais tout d'une app store
outre les cours et sortilèges vous aurez
accès à un grand nombre d'améliorations
de talents et de compétences qui vous
aideront à progresser comme sorciers
relever toutes sortes de défis pour
gagner de l'expérience
renforcer vos compétences avec des
talents améliorant vos sortilèges planté
potion pour augmenter leur puissance
choisissez les talents qui correspondent
à votre style de jeu pour vous
spécialiser dans vos types de magie
préférez vous pouvez aussi trouver
acheter un fabriquer votre éthiquement
magique ce qui améliorera vos
compétences d'attaqué de défense en
combat
l'équipement peut être amélioré et
spécialisés afin de s'adapter au mieux à
votre style de jeu even more than one
cross aignan qui me freine
[Musique]
l'essor ne sont pas les seuls outils à
votre disposition combat développer vos
compétences avec votre baguette magique
et poursuivez votre apprentissage à
poudlard pour vous perfectionner en tant
que sorcière ou sorcier
préparer des potions pour augmenter
votre puissance en cas de besoin
[Musique]
déployer des plantes magiques pour
envahir le champ de bataille et éloigner
les esprits
vous pouvez même libéré de jeunes plants
de mandragore
pour neutraliser les ennemis peau
méfiant
en soins aux créatures magiques vous
vous familiariserez avec différentes
créatures que vous pourrez rencontrer à
l'école mais aussi en explorant les
environs du château qu'on l'attendait
[Musique]
apprendre et maîtriser des compétences
de vol vous permettra de voyager plus
rapidement à travers le monde
pour le 10e mois
certaines compétences peuvent vous être
enseignée par les élèves qui deviennent
vos amis à mesure que vous développez
des relations avec ses camarades ils
pourront vous accompagner dans votre
aventure
et au fil du temps vous découvrirez leur
histoire
[Musique]
natsios nay est une courageuse
aventurière motivée par la soif de
justice poppy sweeting un grand coeur et
adore les créatures magiques elle se lie
à elles plus facilement comme
il ne craint ni les retenue ni les
infractions kendrick
sebastian palau un serpent tard
charismatique
avec un troublant secret de famille n'a
fini qu'à
[Musique]
vous rencontrerez ses élèves et bien
d'autres encore en explorant les salles
communes les couloirs et les lieux de
rencontres habituelles
wj de goom avril 3 min
[Musique]
l'un des secrets les plus fascinants du
château de poudlard et la salle sur
demande
[Musique]
vous découvrez cet espace qui semble
deviner ce dont vous avez besoin et vous
le procurer
[Musique]
comme vous devez rattraper votre retard
la salle vous offre un espace pour
cultiver les plantes préparer des
potions et améliorer votre équipement
un elfe de maison nommée crignier vous
fera découvrir des vivariums qui vous
permettront d'élever vos propres
créatures magiques
cliquez sochaux
aménager cet espace pour qu'il reflète
votre personnalité et vos spécialités
magique
[Musique]
vous ne trouverez pas à poudlard tout ce
dont vous avez besoin pour votre périple
vous visiterez également le village de
pré-au-lard où de nombreux magasins
pourront vous fournir en produits utiles
[Musique]
qu'il s'agisse d'ingrédients et recettes
de potions de graines de plantes
magiques de tout type d'équipement
[Musique]
mais pré au lard n'est pas exempt de
danger un groupe de magie noire mardi
par cette période troublée se promène
aux abords du village
vous devez les éviter ou les vagues
en explorant vous découvrirez que les
environs de poudlard regorge d'activités
de merveilles et d'environnement
insolite tout au long de l'année le
climat et les saisons évolué pour
illuminer le ciel des clercs ou de rayon
de soleil ou recouvrir le sol de neige
ou de pluie
d un mode sorcier parsèment la région
vous y croiserez des vendeurs et des
habitants qui ont des histoires à
raconter et des missions diverses à vous
confier
ouvrez l'oeil et repérer des énigmes
magique qui pourrait bien avoir été
créée par berlin en personne lorsqu'il
était élève à poudlard
créatures magiques road aux alentours de
poudlard certaines ont été corrompus par
une mystérieuse magie noire tandis que
d'autres sont menacés pour les
braconniers si le coeur vous en dit vous
pouvez les sauver pour ensuite les
soigner dans la salle sur demande
mais il existe aussi des dangers qui
dépassent votre compréhension les
cachots et les caveaux renferme de
terribles menaces ainsi que
d'inestimables récompense
faites bien attention à vos choix il
pourrait vous mener sur un chemin plus
maîtriser des sortilèges faites-vous de
nouveaux alliés voyager au coeur d'un
paysage complètement inédit révélé
d'anciens secrets fait face à des
menaces légendaire découvrez des
mystères d'un autre âge devenue la
sorcière ou le sorcier que vous rêvez
d'être et écrivez votre histoire dont le
monde des sorciers
ici dans hogwarts legacy l'héritage de
poudlard
[Musique]